[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your money and your life and your
relationships and your work your mental
health everything give us a shout the
lines are wide open triple eight eight
two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two
five i'm john dalone joined here by
i'm gonna call you my good friend george
campbell thank you thank you for saying
that you there's a lot of hesitation
worthy i first i was gonna tell the
truth and then i forgot the venmo you
sent me and
i told you i'd do it i paid john off to
be nice to me today and i'm grateful for
it john we're back by unpopular demand
exactly dozens called and said we'd love
you all to be on
and uh so they had us back triple eight
eight two five five two two five um
george you have been running and gunning
for a few months walk us through it what
are you doing it's been a little while
uh we have been uh we hustled on the
fine print podcast which was a lot of
fun and we've got a lot of video shoots
and curriculums and things that we're
getting off the ground here at ramsey
and a lot of people don't know this john
our high school curriculum and personal
finance is in 48 of high schools in
america one out of two that's amazing
because a lot of people go man i wish i
learned this stuff when i was in school
john i wouldn't have made these mistakes
in my 20s and 30s and 40s and so it's
really cool to see the impact our team
is having over in ramsey education and
they updated it with you in it and we
had we had a lot of fun yes exactly so
if you're a high schooler tune in and i
love
man i don't want to be dismissive
i'm a pythagorean theorem fan oh no but
my middle school son is going through it
and i thought you know what you really
should be learning right now as i was
doing taxes yes i was doing taxes man
it'd be great if uh they had a class on
what taxes were and why they work and
how to do them um they're not
complicated especially if you have a
great program to get through them but no
man the pythagorean theorem is wearing
me out trying to watch my son drown well
they taught us how to play hot cross
buns on a recorder but they didn't teach
us what deductions and withholdings i'm
just gonna stop you right there hot
cross buns in the recorder that's the
only song people can play i can still
play that's three notes
don't take away my musical prowess we're
not gonna do that on the show today but
what we will do is help you with all of
your questions around money boundaries
relationships
aaa health eight two five five two two
five all right let's stop rambling
people are gonna get frustrated with
listen shut us off let's go to julie in
the big d dallas texas what's up julie
hi uh i'm doing well um
i wanted to ask you about refinancing a
mortgage bring it on what's up
so we currently have an fha mortgage
we are we owe about seventy thousand
dollars
um we i just actually spoke to churchill
uh this morning
um to see if refinancing is a good idea
and they're saying after closing costs
would be like seventy four thousand
dollars
but at the rate we're paying it off i
just don't know if like building in
those closing costs are a good idea for
us um or if it's worth it um because
we've been paying off about 20 to 25 000
a year so far on the mortgage that's
awesome
okay so what what's the rate now and
what would it go to and is it a 30 to 15
um we're on the 30 right now if we go to
the 15 year it would be 3.375
okay
and what's it at right now and
right now it's at 3.625
okay
not a major jump there in interest rate
so so far it's not super tantalizing to
to do the refi but you're knocking off
half of the mortgage the life of the
mortgage but she's saying they're gonna
pay it off in two years anyways that's
my ques yeah julie how long have you
been planning on uh two three years
staying dating
we're thinking probably three we're
having our first child later this year
too congrats
you know i don't know how finances are
going to change at that point as well so
there's a lot of like external factors
here
um are you okay let me run this by you
too we currently pay escrow because it's
fha and there's also pmi that we can't
get rid of yeah um so that would help
because i can
we can save the the insurance and taxes
ourselves
how much other than you save on the
escrow
we have no debt this is the only that we
have
well i mean we can't do the math on
error but i would run all these numbers
and it's you know obviously your
payments going up because of the 15 year
but is that still going to be within
your your 25 of your take-home pay
yes very like you would actually drop it
a little bit overall because you're
losing some of the cost as well moving
to a conventional loan right
wow yeah exactly this is i mean it may
be split in hairs here because you're
not gaining a ton on the interest rate
side so i would run kind of a break even
analysis and go okay are we going to
make are we going to make this up are we
going to make the thousand dollar gap
with the closing costs up within that
three years and if it is the case if
it's hey we're gonna make this up we're
gonna roi this thing in a year and a
half two years then you can go ahead and
do it and julie let me tell you this i
had the same it's very similar thing
right before the turn of the year and i
sat down with churchill and did a very
similar thing
and here's what i loved about my um my
time with them
they told me at the outset
we will
not take your business if it's not a
good move for you so we will tell you we
don't think this is a good move
um and so i would call your churchill
person back and say
um
daloni and i ended up doing it they said
we think this is a great move for you
here's why they walked me through why it
was a good move but i love the fact that
they said at the outset we're not gonna
take your money just to take your money
if it's gonna end up hurting your family
we don't want your business if it's
gonna be at the detriment of your home
and so call them and ask them um
is this ultimately a good decision for
our family and then the follow-up
question is would you do this if you
were in a similar situation and i have
found them to be uber trustworthy and
i've trusted my own family and our own
situation with their refi in the exact
same situation so i think it's worth and
i don't plan on having my mortgage for
more than a couple more years so i think
it's definitely um
worth asking that that hardcore and let
them know hey we're going to pay this
off at this point two and a half three
years so is this going to be worth it if
you're gonna be in there for another 10
years it would absolutely be worth it
but because you guys are on this
timeline to pay it off we generally just
say hey just keep keep staying the
course put as much extra as you can on
there because the interest rate's not
going to make that much of a difference
do you have a matrix george um for
somebody who
[Music]
is just trying to decide whether they're
gonna pay it off not pay it off
i mean if you look decision making your
own budget and you go hey if we're gonna
pay this thing off in two years
generally it's not worth refinancing
unless you're dropping a significant
rate which in this case i mean we're
talking about 23 yeah if it was a full
percentage point we're going okay this
is adding up yeah even over the course
of a year we're gonna save thousands and
thousands of dollars and she's saving
some because of those fha loans they've
got a lot of fees baked into it like
she's talking about with that pmi and so
to have that off your back saving you a
few hundred bucks a month well that
compounds pretty quickly yeah over the
course of a year or two i might my
default is i like any move that's going
to drop off half of the life of the loan
and my monthly payment is going to stay
the same it feels like a win yeah um but
again i think in their picture they're
going to pay it off in two years and i
always man that new baby is always the
that's always a variable it's hard to
wrap your head around yeah but they have
the money for it either way when's it
being when's a big absolute no-no just
walk away from the
you know the refi table
i mean if we're talking it's going to
cost you four five six thousand dollars
and it's going to take years and years
and years to roi that thing i'm going no
refining from a 30 to a 15 just to feel
good about yourself and do the ramsay
plan that doesn't always make sense okay
because it costs you too much to make
them because it costs you too much to
roi on that uh fast enough so it's not
there's no clear-cut thing you've got to
look at the numbers do a break even
analysis on it and go can i get recoup
my investment in this which is your
closing costs fast enough to make this
worth it fantastic triple eight eight
two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five it's
the ramsay show we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show let's go
out to douglas in charlotte north
carolina hey douglas what's going on
[Music]
hey you know yeah i can hear you great
what's going on man
hey man uh i just finally grabbed my
long ago and uh i had a question i'm a
company driver right now a cdl driver
i want to
make a switch to owner operator someday
and
obscurus
should i pay off my consumer debt first
then buy truck cash or
they have my consumer debt and my
mortgage and then buy truck cash
well either way i want you to pay cash
for the truck now let's talk about the
consumer debt what do you have in
consumer debt
so i got i just sold my car um i guess i
just found you guys i'm real you're
getting serious about it man
yes i'm a huge car guy and uh i put a
lot of money in that car but i sold it
paid off my truck too wow
so i got some student loans
one credit card and
mortgage
and that's about it so what's your
non-mortgage debt total
last time i ended it up it's
about 56 000
86 56 56 okay what's your income
right now i am making about 65 000 but
um i'm leaving this job next week to get
another job to increase about 30 000 wow
your income
so you're going to go up to about 95.
yep douglas way to go man that's a huge
jump that's going to help you pay off
this debt how much go on your mortgage
145 145.
well if i'm in your shoes i'm using this
income to my benefit i'm going to keep
living how i've been living keep living
like you're broke and get rid of this 56
000 in debt and get your emergency fund
in place and then i'd be saving up to
pay cash for that truck
before paying off the mortgage yeah i
don't think you ha you have any reason
to have to pay off the mortgage before
starting this business that's not part
of it but i do want this consumer debt
out of your life because number one it's
going to free up a whole bunch of money
for you to pay cash for that truck and
it's going to put a lot less stress on
you as you try to launch out on your own
how much is it
how much is your own truck in your area
um for a decent truck you uh about 40
000. about 40. okay
so you gotta you gotta
you know
two two and a half three year journey
here right
yeah i'm looking at i wanted to be
debt-free
not including the mortgage about 30 i'm
27 now oh you'll be you'll be debt-free
way sooner than that i think you can
probably own this truck by then too
free and clear if you get after it
yeah
i love your heart man and man
congratulations on busting and getting
out of there that's big i love the the
heart of wanting to start out on your
own and when you do that with no
payments it changes everything and i
love that he said i'm a car guy and i'm
selling my cars that means i'm shifting
my suffice shifting my identity from
uh depreciating assets to
i guess i can't say that anymore because
car values keep
refusing cars aren't appreciating that
they're appreciating assets but i'm a
car guy too
i'm a free guy and that's an identity
that's worth shifting for let's go out
to andrew in huntsville alabama what's
up brother andrew how are we doing
all right uh
i'm a engineering student i'm a senior
right now and i graduate in may and um
i've already got a job lined up for
after school
it'll be a salary position making about
forty five thousand
and um well a little more than forty
five but
um i'm wondering
you know i'm looking at probably getting
married within five years or so and
doing some other things i'm wondering
what can i do to try to springboard and
build wealth
quickly when i'm young besides just like
an ira and maybe getting another second
job or something
let me rephrase that
how do i get rich quick
is that why you're asking yeah yeah what
what can i do to not necessarily quick
but
that would um
i want to make sure that i do the things
i need to do now to be where i want to
be when i'm you know 40 and i know that
i can be prepared for retirement and
i've budgeted out you know taking
six grand out every year for maxing up
my high rate but um
i would like to try to find something i
can do to make a
kind of
a uh
alternate stream of income to be able to
enjoy while i'm young like you know
through raising a family and things like
that
um so i was wondering if y'all had any
advice on that
well i've heard you could
draw art pictures on your computer and
sell them for millions he's talking
about nfts don't listen to him andrew
listen ahead and i heard also you could
get imaginary uh
zeros and ones pictures and sell them in
imaginary places on the internet that's
true rich if you're selling them it
might be a good business
but andrew here's what i hear you saying
i want to live life on my terms and i
don't want to wait till retirement to do
it and i love that spirit and i think
you can get there but i think there's
you've got to have a bigger picture than
just how do i invest like a crazy person
and do some
make some money quick i want you to
think bigger than that and go how do i
invest in myself how do i set up my
family for success how do i do you have
any debt right now
uh i have about
nine ninety five hundred
uh in
student loan debt and that's it no car
payments no credit cards
no no car payment i just paid off my car
um a couple months ago awesome so here's
what i want you to do if you walk
through these baby steps if you graduate
and you pay off this 9 500
really fast and you save up three to six
months of expenses
what you're going to be able to do
pretty quickly when you don't have any
debt and you're making 45 50k
then i want you to start investing 15 of
your income into retirement so that will
look like if you've got a 401k at work
i'm going to invest into the match
beyond that you can invest into that
roth ira
and then back to the 401k if they have
one at work once you hit that 15 percent
uh you know you want you might want to
save up for a house right
so that's got to be part of this
equation we can't just take every dime
we can and throw it into investments we
have other pieces of our life that we
have to pay attention to and if you're
talking about you know wanting to be
married in five years are you dating
someone or is this just kind of
aspirational hey i'd like to be married
in five years
i am dating someone i've been dating for
uh about
17 months now um and i mean i wouldn't
be dating them if i didn't think it was
possible in five years or in a couple of
years however long so you're feeling
good about this relationship you want to
prepare for that yes sir let me ask you
this
what kind of engineer are you
uh i have a mechanical electrical
uh engineering technology degree um and
right now i'll be taking a job as a
automotive design engineer
with a company here locally was that the
first option you received
um
well no not necessarily but uh i've
worked there or i've worked kind of
training up through here
since my senior high school
and they have trained me on several
different things to step into this
design i'll be stepping into pretty much
the senior design engineer
position and then within three years
have another evaluation where um
they would evaluate my kind of
contribution and i would be able to have
a um
sharing of the profits
of certain jobs like a percentage-based
sharing so it would be a significant pay
increase
i want you to be
eyes wide open you've you have a
relationship with this company and
you've been with them since you were
young
and
when that happens especially when we're
young we we have an affinity for them
but sometimes that affinity sometimes
that familiarity can cost us tens and
twenties and thirties of thousands of
dollars
and so okay 40 grand for a
i
i just have too many students i've
worked with and know who have left
college with engineering degrees that
are making 85 first job
and then two years in they're at 120 and
then they're at equity stake when they
make partners so
i know that you know this group and i
know it's local and you're going to be
able to hang out in the old places and
talk to the old high school buddies but
i want you to be highly intentional
about your trajectory one of the things
we say here often is your greatest
wealth building tool
your greatest fastest way to get ahead
is to make a great salary not to come up
with some get rich quick scheme and i
was kidding about nfts and i was kidding
about bitcoins and buying imaginary
things in imaginary universes um i want
you to be really intentional about your
salary okay and what your value is what
you're worth and of course you never go
to a place that's going to kill you that
you hate to make more money
but man i also say you don't stay at a
place that makes you feel comfortable
especially when you're young and you're
supposed to be grinding it out in these
years
for half of your market value for a
third of your market value right so be
super intentional about that salary um
if they're gonna give you a track make
sure you got it in writing that this is
the plan because i've heard too many
yeah in a couple years we're really
gonna reimagine this or reevaluate this
and a couple years goes by real fast and
there's not a lot of reimagination
stay the course man you can do this and
i want you to have a paid for house and
then you can get into real estate
investments and create that passive
income you're so young you got your
whole life ahead of you be patient stay
the course
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five i'm john deloney joined here by my
good friend
as promised george campbell we're taking
your calls on money life
relationships
work all of it triple eight eight two
five five two two five all right george
um this is a conversation for you and
you can help out me the old man i will
help you even though we're basically the
same age
tick tock faces an investigation into
its impact on young people's mental
health
coalition of state attorneys from
california florida look at california
and florida get on the same team
maybe something good is happening the
world's coming together kentucky
california and florida and kentucky same
page i'm calling this a win already and
more is investigating tick-tock for its
potential effect on young people's
mental and physical health
group of ag's is looking to see the way
tick-tock designs operates and markets
its platform has a negative effect on
children teens and young adults health
according to press release by the ag of
massachusetts so
um a couple things that i find troubling
about tick tock and again if
me ranting about social media is no big
news but this is this is more personal
for me
um
my i have a middle schooler
and
he came home and was talking about what
is this tick tock thing because of
course he lives in the 14th century
because he lives in our house and all of
his classmates were on tick tock and did
he just have an abacus he placed with at
home that's what i'm picturing at the
delony house he has a stick and a small
stone and that's pretty much his toys
and he uh
he i said what are some things your
friends tell you about so he gave us the
name of somebody on tick tock a tick
tock star and so my wife and i pull it
up
and it was
again
i
my entire show is
is about relationships and sexuality
intimacy i am
far from an old-fashioned prude right
what i saw on that was a
very young kid
super provocative super um
it was just highly it was it was it
reminded me of my time working with
sexually abused kids it was highly
sexually charged up and it was really
young kids doing these dances whatever
and it wasn't just it's a fun hilarious
tick tock dances which i've seen i've
been a part of those this is something
totally different and
my initial thought was i don't want my
kids exposed to this and i don't want my
kids
longing to
become the topic of conversation
and i started to ask myself what is the
trajectory here for this product for
tick tock and i realized that it's
different so
you know remember saturday morning
cartoons um we had those back in the uh
dinosaur era that's the only thing we
have in common age-wise we both had
cartoons um they you know they had these
shiny cereals and cool toys and things
like that that they had you know
whiz-bang and and lots of shiny moments
so that kids would want to buy those
but the whole object of those
commercials was to get your kids to tell
your parents that's what i want they
still had to loot back to the parents
and this feels new because what this is
doing is going to aft directly after the
kids it's bypassing any sort of um wise
or mature
filter going directly into the hearts of
minds kids
and that feels different and i'm happy
to see
states coming together states that
on the surface don't like each other are
coming together to say hey
they write here how tick-tock keeps
people watching and engaging is somewhat
mysterious they have had to pay millions
of dollars in fines
um tic toc has already for how they're
going after children under the age of
13.
um
man i
as somebody who doesn't consume
tick-tock regularly
um help me out with the redeeming value
i can help you john so
to to tick-tock's defense i am a big
consumer those words have never been
uttered in the history of the english
language by the way here's the thing uh
you know a lot of people assume tick
tock is a bunch of salacious dance
challenges but what's extra dangerous is
how good the algorithm is at learning
what you like okay and so it doesn't ask
you there's no survey that says hey
george are you interested in personal
finance and food hacks it didn't ask me
that it just learned over time the kind
of content i was engaging in so i don't
see dance challenges what i see is a lot
of content creators you know trying to
build their followings trying to sell an
online course whatever you know a lot of
the bitcoin bros that are out there
trying to teach you on whatever the next
coin you should invest in
so i do see a lot of value in
short form content creation it's where
things are going it's where we've been
heading we we have a shorter attention
span than ever and even the cartoons
these days if you watch them there's a
new scene change every three or four
seconds
because it's just bright garbage and you
need to keep your attention by switching
scenes cutting cameras we are losing our
attention span so that to me is one of
the most dangerous parts it's not the
salacious dance challenges it's the fact
that i can't focus anymore i can't even
sit through a two-hour movie yeah
because i gotta oh where's my phone i
can't drive to the grocery store without
trying to text and drive and get emails
so to me the danger is in what short
form content could be doing to our
attention spans to our focus and that's
that's we can't pay attention to
conversations anymore it's a
neurological consequence right it's
changing how our brain is wired together
um
so you said you were going to defend
tick tock and i feel like you might join
my team i love the content that i see on
tick tock i find it more valuable than
some things i see on youtube i just
watched one yesterday and it was a girl
explaining what's going on with ukraine
and nato and she did it in a really
funny kind of almost like she was
gossiping to a friend about it and she
explained it in 60 seconds so concisely
and perfectly and made and entertained
me along the way so i think there is
value in the style of content there's
value in a platform like tick tock which
you know like it or not has done this
really well of serving you up content
that it thinks you will like and then
keeping you engaged
so on that side i mean that's just smart
marketing that's how the content machine
works it's why we love watching youtube
video after youtube video and now it's
now it's tick tock and so it sounds like
the metal lesson then is no pun intended
is parents have to continue to remain
parents because asking a 10 year old or
a 14 year old to
look at cooking videos over
salacious videos or extra violent
content or whatever
um is it's
you're asking too much of a small kid
right yes i'm a grown man it's very
different for me versus a 13 year old
especially if you have kids out there i
can't imagine what it's like being a
parent and trying to you know make sure
that you're aware of what your kid is
engaging in what apps that they're
downloading and part of the all the
drama with tick tock is that there's no
no need for parents permission kids can
just download this app make their
account and have free rein over all the
content on there yeah
and man
i trust you you're smart and you're wise
and you do your due diligence if
somebody said hey i've been getting a
lot of updates on what's going on
overseas
via tiktok
i would just shake my head in the
sadness you know what i mean yeah so
also be careful about where what you're
getting too well this is their news
platform now yeah they're not checking
cnn and fox news anymore teens are just
going on tick tock that's great either
but and they're just learning from
people their age about what's going on
and so take everything with a grain of
salt yep tick tock is not gospel it is
not the dictionary so do your due
diligence but it's a fun entertaining
platform i use it to learn things and to
be entertained but if you've got a kid
out there you've got to be really
careful about how this is affecting your
teen with comparison culture and both
content-wise and neurologically right
yeah because it used to be i want to be
a youtuber john that's the new goal of
every high schooler now is i want to be
a tick-tock influencer and i want to
make content what's my content going to
be how am i going to hook people in and
they get obsessed with this with all the
likes all the engagement all the
comments and all the critics and every
negative comment that comes through that
affects you mentally that sticks with
especially kids right dave and i just
read mean tweets yesterday it doesn't
affect us like it would a teenager
you know we'd have thicker skin than i
did at 14 years old well you remember a
few things people said to you when you
were 14 right there's a comment that
still sticks with me when i was 14
uploaded a youtube video and they said
it was it was a me covering umbrella by
rihanna on acoustic guitar and they said
you killed it dot dot dot and not in a
good way
and it stuck with me because it was
funny it was creative but it hurt but
there's something about these strangers
that are critics on the internet and we
take it personally and go this is a
reflection on my character and who i am
and so you've got to be really careful
not just about what you're posting what
you're engaging in but what other people
are saying that you don't even know
so
man i just loot back to two big things
number one if you're wondering can i
have a job can i have a life if i don't
engage in this
i don't and i seem to be doing okay and
the second thing is
please be highly diligent with your kids
just hand in your kid a device or a box
a digital babysitter insane go get them
and make good choices
is just a recipe for disaster that the
data on children's mental health and
their engagement with social media
continues to just be jaw-dropping i
think it's going to be one of the
biggest issues for that generation that
we've got to grapple with
and parents are the start of it they've
got to have these conversations
triple at 825 5225 we'll be right back
on the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm john dalone
joined here by ramsey personality george
campbell and we're taking your calls on
life and money let's go to nathaniel in
harrisburg pennsylvania what's up
nathaniel
yes i am
my question is i have a small business
where i do delivery of dogs and drive
people around
and right now with the gas prices i am
being killed yeah
um
i
yesterday my wife and i just put our
first budget together
and
i'm just wondering how
how do i budget for expenses for my
business
well i'm in a sense you're budging the
same way you would for your personal
finances so i would look at all of your
expenses for your business and make sure
that you're charging enough that you're
able to cover all those costs and still
pay yourself so is that the case right
now
um
right now i'm i'm doing okay but the um
like with my dog delivery people are
starting to turn down my services
because i had to raise my prices
so nathaniel okay um
how honest can i be with you right now
yeah
can i be pretty honest with you is that
okay yeah okay
whenever i
get
scared
whenever i get angry
i don't make good choices i don't make
good decisions and i don't treat people
around me okay
i filled up my truck yesterday and it
was a
like my eyes bulged out there's a lot
and i have a little secret gas station
that i use here in nashville
i call it a secret it's not but they
just happen to have gas prices that are
way cheaper than everybody and it was it
was hard
and so i was sad for a minute i was
frustrated for a minute and any choice i
make to be angry and raged out after
that is a choice for me to be miserable
and i can hear it in your voice that
you're pissed off and you're angry
and that usually leads me and most
people to not make great choices and so
you run a business and this hurts and
this is scary
and the gas prices went up
so
have a moment where you're angry about
it have a moment where you're frustrated
and you are doing a good thing and
you're helping people out and suddenly
you're having to make hard choices about
whether you could do this thing anymore
and then let's quickly as possible move
to okay here's the new reality i'm going
to own the reality and then what comes
next what's the pivot
and it might be for a season i'm not
delivering dogs anymore because i'm
losing business because i can't afford
to do this job anymore and it's the same
if you sold jet airplanes and all of a
sudden steel got expensive
or you you know were a construction
engineer and steel got i mean and wood
got expensive right
and so
what you're asking us is to say like is
there a secret hack here and there's
really not your your material cost for
your business just went way up and so
things got expensive and you had to
adjust your prices and now people are
saying i can't afford those prices
that's the state of the world right now
literally the state of the globe so give
us an idea i know you've thought about
some ideas what's a pivot you can make
i have a lot of i've thought about
getting some small jobs around my area
um
like i i love butchering um so i'm
thinking about um talking to some
veterans in my area
i love that what about going to uh
you seem to be good with pets can you
walk dogs instead of driving around i'm
just making stuff up man i don't know
what you're doing i'm i'm out in the
country not very many people have
that's not a
thing
that people do out in the country uh
what does a small business make right
now
um i'm making approximately 2 400 a
month
okay
and is that all of your income
yeah and is that all profit
no
this worries me this doesn't feel i mean
you're living at the poverty level at
this point
yeah
what's your goal for this business
um
well i've been doing it for eight years
and i've and i
i'm actually going to be going to the
mission field in several years so i'm
not looking for anything long term right
now
but you can go get a job for five years
that's you know a full-time position
until you leave for the mission field
but making 28 grand after running a
business for eight years and that's not
even your profit that's a bad that's a
bad business it's not working out you're
not running a sustainable business my
man even aside from gas prices
yeah i can hear that hurting your voice
because man you've put your a lot of
your heart and mind and soul and i bet
you're really are you good at this
sounds like you're good at this
yeah
or let me even ask it sounds like you
care about the people whose dogs are
driving around and
delivering things it sounds like you
care about this is that right
yeah i do yeah
so
i'm just going to give you my secret
hack when things get spun out on me like
this i have a note card and i wish it
was more sophisticated maybe one day
i'll make an app i'll get with george i
won't make an app but
i literally write down what can i
control on this and what can i cannot
and what you can control is how you
treat people your work ethic your ideas
your
desire to help others all those things
you can control all that
control number one you can't control gas
prices
not in the middle of a global chaos like
we have right now number two i can't
control that my minimum price has to be
x or i actually lose money doing my job
and you can't control number three that
people will not pay that price so i've
got to do something else what can i
control number four doing something
different and it might be a season yeah
you go work fast food cause you're gonna
make more money or you go work at
starbucks you're gonna make more money
or you go become a farm hand out there
in the country in harrisburg whatever it
looks like
but take the season mourn it grieve it
it's it's heartbreaking like i don't
want to make light of it but
i want you to let some of that rage
leave you otherwise you're going to end
up making a tough decision or a not well
thought out decision you're going to
take out a loan you're going to get mad
at somebody you're going to end up just
setting yourself on fire
instead of solving the problem at hand
which is i gotta make some money is that
fair
yes okay and my hope is man i hope gas
prices return i don't see it on the
horizon it looks like we got a mess on
our hands i'm not a profit of course
when it comes to gas prices but
i would think more than a month more
than two months within three months man
you're already running a business this
really has no margin at all it's not
making any money nathaniel i want to do
you another favor here i'm gonna have
kelly pick up and we're gonna send you a
copy of our friend ken coleman's book
from paycheck to purpose and i think
that will give you some ideas on how to
get clear about what you're really
wanting to do it feels like right now
you've been spinning your wheels trying
to get this business off the ground
you're heading into the mission field
years from now potentially but there's a
lot of life you've got to live in
between that and i want you to do
something that you love and also get
paid really well to do it you're worth
that so hang on kelly will pick up and
we will get you a copy of from paycheck
to purpose thanks for the call let's
let's slide in one more call here curtis
in you know what we're not going to make
it are we
no we're going to make it yeah let's all
right curtis and wichita let's do this
real quick and go there curtis run up
we're up against the clock so we'll get
to your question quick brother
hey uh i was just wondering i've just
started listening to you all and i i
want to get my wife involved in this but
she's
we we have a lot of squabbles about
money and i was wondering what the best
way to approach
you know kind of coming up with hey we
got to get out of debt here's something
i found
will you sit down and do this with me
most of the time i've seen this
conversation when it doesn't go well is
people make the conversation about money
they make the conversation about tactics
they make a conversation about you did
this and i did this and i have to do
this and so you got to sell that
and those are all peripheral issues to
the core issue
which is
honey i'm scared to death i can't
breathe
i can't sleep
i don't believe we've got
enough gas in the tank to get us over
the next year or the next two years and
this is scaring me to death and i don't
have a picture of what this looks like
but i just found this total money
makeover book i just found this podcast
of this guy this crazy guy dave and his
in his squadron of goons who are telling
us to live different lives
i'm terrified and
i'm being vulnerable here i'm telling
you this
and i've got a plan for us would you
join me in this can we have a picture of
what it would look like if we both do
this together and then we're free on the
other end of this that's a much
different conversation than we owe too
much money you're gonna have to sell
that car and uh i'm gonna keep the
motorcycle but i'm probably gonna hear
what i'm saying
very different conversations
go at the heart piece and you go first
have you done that part yet
uh
no not really we're just you know we're
we've lived a normal life for the last
12 years we've been married and filed
bankruptcy twice
and uh are you a guy who's always you a
guy that's always got a plan
an idea
no i always think i do but really i
don't that's right and she's probably
heard a lot of your schemes and a lot of
your plans and a lot of your oh this is
gonna work honeys and she's not having
it this is when you be vulnerable and
tell her honey i'm scared and this time
i'm gonna do something different thank
you so much for that call curtis hey
that's the first hour in the books we'll
be right back on the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john delony co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
what is going on we are live from the
headquarters of ramsey solutions this is
the ramsay show where america hangs out
to have a conversation about your money
and your life and your relationships
your mental health whatever's going on
your life i'm john deloney joined here
by my good friend george campbell and we
are taking your calls on anything
everything
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five
five
two two
five let's go out to mara in buffalo new
york what is up mara
hi guys thanks for taking my call thank
you for trusting us with your time
what's up
okay i'll make it as quick as i can no
take your time
okay i've been a police officer the last
10 years and
in 2009 i switched to teaching full-time
so i went down to part-time um we
recently found you guys and we've been
hammering these baby steps and we're on
number two um
i've been struggling with keeping the
law enforcement job mentally for years
and i guess i'm just wondering um i wait
just part time i have four jobs and i
make about 300 a shift waitressing in a
day between two to three hundred and as
a police officer i only make take home
about like 60
and mentally i'm kind of done with it
but i just
you know i have about 5 000 in my
deferred comp there i can't touch it
until i leave
another positive is that my time will
transfer into the state retirement as a
teacher but i just i don't know if i'm
ready to like pull the plug and i don't
know what to do um i make about five
thousand a year now like i said i do
about one shift a week as a police
officer but waitressing i can make about
15 to 20 000.
so i just i guess
i don't know if i'm making the right
move to finally close that chapter
or
do i hold on to it
so why did you become a police officer
um
i became a police officer because i love
my community my brother actually does it
full-time i pretty much wanted to do
everything like him i work in the
hometown where i grew up i also teach
here too so i'm with the same community
um
but
it's just it's not what it was when i
first started i also have three children
now
so it's not
you know what i mean i'm not young
anymore
um i worry about coming home to my
babies um
what i do i primarily dispatch now so i
don't even like to go out on the road
anymore just because there's no if i get
hurt um i'm not covered like i was when
i was full time you know what i mean
yeah too much risk now than there was
but mara let's be honest um and most
people won't know this from externally
but dispatch will take your soul
because those are your boys
those are your boys right and every time
you put somebody in danger you sit there
and you don't breathe until they radio
back that they're out right absolutely
and so most people don't understand the
depths of hell that being a dispatcher
is um some of the most egregious trauma
i've ever been around is was walking
alongside dispatchers and when they lose
somebody or somebody gets yelled at or
screamed at or hurt or something um the
dispatchers that i've known in my life
are deeply invested in this and so
absolutely it's one thing to say yeah
i'm not actively being shot at but to
say you're not being affected like isn't
accurate you're being deeply affected
every day right
and then you don't breathe for your
whole 10-hour shift or 12-hour shift and
then you go home and you have to exhale
and you've got three little babies who
are using you like a jungle gym right
and now we're in it again um so let's
reverse that question you told me that
you wanted to serve and you want to be
like your big brother both noble things
let's picture a world where you're not a
police officer at all anymore you're
just done you say you hang it up you say
hi
you high five everybody you get your
donuts or your your cookies or whatever
and they tell you
you hug everybody and then you all go to
the bar and then it's over take me there
is that a joyful moment is that a sad
moment
i think it's bold i think that
mentally
i haven't worked the road since about
um 2018 i had a couple close calls so i
switched it inside and then i knew when
i went off on maternity i had my son and
i wasn't going back i found a teaching
job and i've now almost done with two
masters
so i think mentally i've been working
towards it and i think that i would
still have that brotherhood because i've
done this for 10 years but i just i
think i just need to push like i said i
only bring home about 60 a day after a
shift there and it's not
and you're leaving 250 a day of your
soul right so i'm gonna give you i'm
gonna give you a quote and i want you to
tattoo it on your heart okay
just because it's hard and just because
it hurts doesn't mean it's wrong
okay
so
when you say goodbye to the one of the
most unique and deeply intertwined
fraternities on the planet
which is a police officer brotherhood
brother and sisterhood
when you say goodbye to that you're
leaving a part of yourself there you
know that they know that because you've
literally stood in harm's way for one
another that's what you do there yeah
and you stood in harm's way
of your community
hours and hours and the community didn't
even know you were there
and
sometimes it's time to go and you're a
person of service you found another
avenue to serve your community through
teaching and here's if you go if you
quit teaching you're going to find
another way to serve you probably serve
your people as a waitress by smiling at
them and you you're somebody who says
hey how's it going and you asked him
that one other question that can make
their day better in just a few minutes
right so yeah you're a person of service
that's who you are you're going to find
avenues to serve
but just because it hurts doesn't mean
it's not the right thing to do and so
spend a minute thinking
all right i'm not going back there
anymore i'm going to leave it all i'm
done
imagine that is that a smile that comes
to your is it that maybe maybe it's not
even a smile it's a lifted way see if
you can hear
you feel it so i think you've answered
your own question
and
i love this
i tell parents when we're talking about
parenting questions i always tell them
when they ask me about their kids i
always say hey behavior is a language
so if i was a to apply that algorithm to
you and say behavior is a language
here's what i've seen over the last few
years
you started becoming a teacher
you got one two master's degree to make
yourself a better teacher
you started getting other jobs like
waitressing just to balance the gap of
the police officer shifts you're not
taking
and now you've got one tiny pinky toe
still in the in the precinct
every other part of your body's left and
so if i look at behavior as a language i
would tell you you've already left
yeah i think that's fair you just
haven't said goodbye yet
yeah
so maybe it's time to say goodbye and
know this your community's gonna miss
you they're gonna miss the crap out of
you
they're gonna miss you yeah i think so
it might be it might be the right time
it might be the right time i've got a
quick question for you do you want to be
a full-time waitress what do you really
want to do if the money was no obvious
no i i i love i love teaching i love it
um the waitressing that's just to um
it's my family's restaurant so it's
extra income it helps them because we're
short staff
and um
it's i'm hammering out baby step two
with our family we're going gazelle and
uh like i said it's almost triple the
income a shift because it sounds like
the long term is i want to be a teacher
full time and i'm doing the waitressing
stuff to help my family and to pay off
debt but long term i want to be a
teacher
yes awesome so i
go back and listen to this call you've
answered your own question i'm not gonna
be the guy that tells you to pull the
trigger and tells you to leave
but it'll be all right if you do we're
so grateful for your service mara so
grateful for the person you are and the
community member you are your
community's lucky to have you buffalo
shout her out we need more mars in the
world we want to serve their communities
way more awesome we'll be right back
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the ramsey show let's go to
casey out in dallas texas what's up
casey
hey how's it going brother we are
rocking on to the breaking down my man
what's up
oh nothing much out here trying to make
some money um i had a question
uh you got real gazelle attempts about
you know getting out of bed hey real
quick hey casey
talking to you talking to your uh phone
there man yeah it is it's in the it's in
the phone okay
okay can you hear me now you're good a
little bit better go for it sounds like
you're on the road or something okay
yeah um anyway i was calling to see
what i should do with my car okay um
i
i counted on a six year loan 14 interest
um i owe 19 on it
the cars were 15 6 from an offer from
carmax
um i don't know if i should just pay the
difference and to get out from the car
because i haven't paid for a truck
already it's just a little older sell it
private sale today
because you'll you'll get
you'll get a wash selling a private sale
you think so put on facebook marketplace
put on craigslist and at least give
yourself a couple of weeks
okay okay yeah i didn't i mean i know
the kelly blue book on it was about the
same as
selling it to carmax it was ranging from
15 5 to 16 time but i mean the market is
a little higher right now somebody
do you have the cash to pay the
difference right now
um by next friday i will okay if you end
up there i won't hurt my feelings
because you got another truck already
paid off
it wouldn't hurt my feelings i mean it's
it's a 99 f250 it's got
350 000 miles on i mean it's kind of
high mileage but yeah but it's just
getting started that car is going to
last forever
i mean you got 14 interest man just
doing the math makes you want to throw
up
i know and that was the thing is like i
look at it now because you know they
take much the interest right off the top
of the loan so it's like i paid 6 000 of
the 10 000 interest besides what the car
actually costs
i think you you list this thing today
and on the contingency that it's picked
up next friday and you can pay the
difference on the loan when it does sell
and we kiss this thing goodbye and so
yeah i would try to list it even if you
just have to list it even so it's even
money when you sell it um try that for a
week and if not go back to carmax get
your money in and then they'll do it
they're going to want to negotiate a
little bit they won't have much margin
in this market but you know list it for
for where you'd have a clean deal there
and if they come down a little bit you
should have the cash to cover the
difference but yeah that's what i do i
bet i'm selling this car before i can
before the weekend of next before next
weekend's over for sure absolutely all
right let's go out to will in nyc what's
up will
hey how you guys doing outstanding
brother what are you up to
all right i got three separate
retirement accounts that i've never
contributed to but i'm leaving one job
and hopefully starting another one next
month i'm just wondering
if it'd be beneficial to convert any of
this
like i got two 401ks and then a separate
annuity
are you getting laid off about 21 000.
are you getting laid off are you
quitting
uh it was kind of an injury thing so
it's kind of quitting and getting laid
off okay and when you say i hope to have
a job next month you have something
lined up
yeah i got an interview on monday
uh if not i'll probably wind up going
back so i'm like i'm not fully
terminated okay just yet but i know that
the union has closed out my account okay
well good luck on your interview here at
the moment okay
so circle back walk me through again
what you're talking about
what are your accounts so i'm just
wondering if
the if i'm leaving this job and the two
accounts that i have are going to start
but one annuity is going to start to pay
out and i think it's like once a month
for 10 years and the other one's just a
401k should i conv like
should i put the 2 401 k's together on
one account should i try to do something
into an ira
i would do a direct rollover to an ira
that's going to give you the most
control and you're not going to have any
tax implications that way
okay
and that'll give you the most investing
options i don't like the idea of these
just sitting around with your old
employer so i want you to do a direct
rollover you can contact one of our
smartvestor pros in your area jump onto
ramseysolutions.com and they can walk
you through the best option for you
which and i'm guessing is going to be a
direct rollover to an ira so that you
have full control over that and it'll
stay with you and not with any employer
okay it will
i just did this when i came to ramsey i
had
401s all over the place 403s all over
the place
and it's a pain in the butt you have to
get on the phone with your advisor and
they have to talk for you and it's a
whole thing and you sign some papers and
then all of a sudden you look up and
it's all rolled over into one place in
one on the same account it's all rolled
over there and it's nice and smooth yeah
so it's a pain and it's worth every
every minute you spend on it
all right get it done brother appreciate
your time you bet hey uh george can you
uh can can you roll out of an annuity
uh i believe you can okay yeah i think
it depends on the type of annuity
because there's a whole bunch of types
here but you should be able to roll over
that into an ira just like you would
your old 401k
uh there's there's variable there's fix
so i would work with a smart investor
pro to walk through what the
implications of that but annuities in
general are a no-no they're in our world
garbage that's right so that's to say if
you roll out of that absolutely take
your money and go there yeah and you'll
have full control that way that's right
all right daniel in macon georgia what's
up daniel how are you doing
hey guys hey
excellent excellent what's up
hey i got a question uh so my wife and i
we're on baby step number two
and we are snowballing debt and we just
paid off thirteen thousand dollars in
debt just in past like three weeks let's
go um so we we're trying to we're a
gazelle intense trying to get this done
as fast as we can
um we have a question though we have a
piece of farm equipment
that is their base interest
no matter what there's no like deadline
there's no
month end on it it is zero based length
of the law
um and then we have a vehicle that has
an interest rate on it
uh and our goal was to kind of pay off
the vehicle first because
of the interest however we owe less on
the piece of farm equipment than we do
the vehicle
so
about 20 000
okay and you paid off 13k in three weeks
so it sounds like you could pay yes
the 20 grand
part of that was tax return and then my
wife's also a realtor so she had a good
month
that's not guaranteed money so we live
off of my paycheck i'm actually a pastor
and uh and i was i was in the military
for a while too we have some some coming
in from that and we live off of that and
we pay debt with the extra income that
she makes in the occasional side job
that i did from time to time got it
and what's left on the other debt the
car
about 30 000
i'm paying off the farm equipment first
yep no ifs ands or buts how much do you
make
uh so with my uh with the church and
also with my military about five
thousand a month
is that total household income
uh that well because hearts are so
erratic we don't really count hers
unless it's you know a good month or
something that just goes forward
yeah that is that is the entire
household that has a lot of car for a 60
000
a year income
okay have you thought about selling that
car and
really cut down we did we actually the
dealership actually offered us
offer to buy it back from us
um and then put us in a older
we have five children to put us in an
older van
which it would have been fine but
the payments were the exact same yeah
why are they putting you back in
payments
i'm not doing that deal yeah i'm not
gonna get into it exactly so we actually
kept we actually kept our newer van
because it was actually well how much
could you sell it for payment
probably i don't know
third i really don't know they offered
they offered us
like two or three grand under what it
was at the time
if you can sell that thing and get out
from under it that's going to clean this
up because you guys have too much car
for the income right now for where
you're at i know you got five kid you
got five kids and two of you so that's
seven people so you get an old beater
minivan right now
and getting rid of this yeah getting to
and from but if you can sell that thirty
thousand dollar car even if you have to
take out a loan for a fifteen thousand
dollar car a ten thousand dollar car
um that's a total now you're talking
about a totally different ball game and
yeah sell that farm equipment first i
don't care about the interest rate i
care about the psychology of those do it
right i start caring about math after we
go into debt
that's not how it works that's right get
that sucker paid off and run run run to
the end zone here we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 thousand dollars about two
years after that i got a remote job that
pays me hundred and thirty thousand
dollars all thanks to what i learned at
bethel tech you could be next get
started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
we are back on the ramsey show and on
the debt free stage
two beautiful good folks dylan and
lauren how are we doing pretty great how
about you i'm assuming i'm doing great
uh we don't ever know about george but
i'm assuming that because you're on the
debt free stage that you are here to do
your debt free scream yes we are
congratulations so how much have you
paid off we paid one hundred twenty
thousand seven hundred and eighty three
dollars let me just check that note yep
ninety three dollars
not that we're counting every penny
right and where do y'all live we live in
pittsburgh pittsburgh and so what do
y'all do for a living
i'm an orthodontic dental assistant so i
do like the wire changes x-rays and
stuff
yeah and i'm an energy strategist
energy strategy that sounds like a job
my my five-year-old self would make up
that's what i'm gonna do when i grow up
and you're doing it i'm gonna strategize
about some energy and stuff excellent
how much you make
we currently make about 130k 130k a year
fantastic how long did it take you to
pay off 120 000
one year 11 months and four days good
night who did you sell what tell us this
journey what happened yeah um we'll uh
we graduated from college in 2019 and we
really got on the bandwagon right around
then
now i had been working a lot of jobs
before that but that's really when we
kicked it into gear and we went from
about seventeen thousand dollars and
combined eighteen thousand dollars in
confined income all the way up to 130 in
this time period so wow so what was this
120 000 debt
college yep all my college student loan
debts
yeah the way lauren looked at you before
she answered that question
so what did you study
i studied energy business and finance so
it was directly correlated but still
super expensive wow so 120 000
how in the world did y'all figure out
how to pay this much off in one year and
11 months
the dave ramsey books
um yeah and doing everything underneath
the sun that we possibly could it was
working late nights uh
ubering
i even was a
i was a food server at a country club
when i moved over to pittsburgh and i
was serving my co-workers on a regular
basis for my day job and it's humbling
what'd they say to you when you walked
up we're like whoa what are you doing
here man
it's it's a little bit of that they also
understand i mean for young so i mean
they they get it but it's
they also don't understand why someone
would be able to work a high flute and
corporate job and then turn around and
go serve people at the other side of it
how old are you two i'm 25. i'm 23.
wow wow okay so take me back to the
original conversation somebody sat down
with somebody and said uh we owe 120 000
dollars we need to get bonkers about
this
you want to go first right with me uh
you can go it was kind of you i think
who initiated yeah so
my my uh
i'll say
i only started realizing how much in
trouble i was in
my junior year of college and it didn't
really hit me though
until i started dating this girl that i
really really liked and realized that
please be lauren please be lord
the thing is that i realized that i'd be
bringing all this debt into this
relationship and that really helped me
kick in in gear when i was like i don't
want to burden us let alone someone who
has no student loan debt and say hey you
should marry this guy who hoes so owes
so much money and is just
sat down and i started working with it
and
she
enjoyed the idea and we just kept going
afterwards i bet she did so lauren
tell me this did you feel did you feel
the weight that he was feeling of this
debt coming into the marriage uh
especially in college when i saw him
selling plasma twice a week did you want
me to bring that up
yeah he has a scar on his own actually
um so that'll be there forever but just
seeing him like eat ramen or skip meals
altogether i was like hey i want to like
do this with you and i don't think i was
ever like as gung-ho um as he was in
college but like we kind of both like
when we got married we got married um
august last year um we both started
living like that i never sold plasma
because they didn't they said my veins
were too tiny but
you didn't need that so you started
paying this off in college is when you
got gazelle intent i started saving up
money during that time period i didn't
make the actual first payment until
after graduation for you very wise very
very wise but you guys were willing to
do whatever it took to get this out of
your life and a lot of people ask they
say well you know would you marry
someone who who has debt and clearly the
answer was yes as long as he was wanting
to pay this off aggressively i think it
was a pretty good deal yeah
it paid off man you guys are amazing
okay so what would you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is
um i'll go on that one yeah it was
starting with a plan having a vision for
that future and then
just hard work
luck is a product of hard work and
some people look at me and say hey
you're a college kid out of like two
years out and you're making a lot of
money like that's
crazy but
you got lucky and the truth is that i
was working 16 to 20 hours a day
it's not luck it's hard work so
hard work and hard work and hard work
and what would you tell
the the millions
millions of young couples who find
themselves in your exact situation we
owe six figures of student loans we're
staring at each other and i think i like
you but oh
man we just jumped into a river with
with
concrete chained to our feet right it's
gonna be hard to breathe for a few what
do you tell those couples don't put it
off don't normalize debt get out of it
as fast as you can that's the only way
it won't you know bite you in the butt
later so on on the other side of this
have you had the
that incredible feeling have you
received a paycheck had your paychecks
deposit and you don't owe anybody
anything and it's all yours
so we paid off our debt today
oh my goodness yeah so our final payment
uh we wire transferred it last yesterday
on the car ride to nashville
and got our practice of the debt free
stream then but it didn't go through
until this morning so just in the nick
of time yeah he's checking your bank
statements
so i actually heard over the police
scanner two young people screaming out
at the top of their car while they're
driving down the highway that must have
been you two yeah i was joking with him
we gotta roll our windows down so that
like when we speed past people all they
hear is
so this is yesterday so you'll have the
the benefit here in a few weeks when you
get your next round of paychecks yeah
that it deposits and you go to make that
payment and you think oh oh this is ours
yeah well we actually
it all happened because my bonus payout
just came perfectly on time today and so
that's why this was able to happen
and
because of that though it actually
pushed us all the way from
in baby step two all the way all the way
to baby step four oh wow
now yep and we're ready to go uh like
have a good time now because it's ours
and we have some cash to go dropping a
50 tip on a bill last night because we
could that's amazing it's just great
that's so good and i love that your
first impulse was to give last night too
we're gonna have fun and by the way
we're gonna give and that's gonna be fun
too uh who are your biggest cheerleaders
so i'd say first was my
family my family started with me i think
first and then they your parents got on
board with it right afterwards
understanding where we're coming from
and they're like hey my daughter's
marrying this crazy guy but um they got
on board and they're great support for
that as well
i also have a financial coach uh and
actually did that as another psychic i
helped him out doing financial coaching
too through dave ramsey's uh site and
that was john murdock at waypoints
financial services so very cool little
shout out there but i'm very cool yeah i
just wanted to um shout out to my aunt
lee because she let me live with her for
several months before we got married and
i was able to set aside the money that i
would have spent on rent um and like
just pay that completely toward the debt
so it sounds like it was a whole team
effort once you said we're gonna put our
noses down you had some people come
around you that lifted you up when this
thing was hard
and you all really got after it really
got after it so
one year 11 months
making about a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars you paid off a hundred
and twenty thousand and some change
you are now debt free so in front of
in front of you you two
in front of the whole world in front of
the planet
counted down let's hear your jeffrey
scream
three three two one we're dead free
[Applause]
[Music]
i love
watching young couples who a still like
each other that's big who be
they're like gross enough i know well
they're they're so young they're
newlyweds and they're debt-free and they
just went on a great adventure together
and they paid off all their debt and
we're gonna give you guys a copy of baby
steps millionaires and total money
makeover you're gonna pass this on to
someone else get them started on the
journey we're so proud of you guys
that's the next step for you millionaire
status let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
over the last 30 years i've walked with
thousands of people and their families
to help them overcome their
challenges things that they're going
through in their life i got a new book
available for pre-order called own your
past change your future and it's selling
like crazy it's going real well pretty
excited about it
everyone wants and needs
this information this idea that you're
not broken you're not dysfunctional some
stuff happened to you and what can we do
about it some of the stuff that happened
to you might have been your fault even
what do we do next right so own your
past change your future is going to talk
to you how to deal with different types
of trauma how to get connected how to
make friends as an adult what do you do
next how to take control of your
thoughts and your actions everything
right and there's
some principles that you can walk that
take with you as you walk the rest of
your life when good stuff happens when
hard stuff happens with scary things but
things we can't control all of it and
here's what's really beautiful our
friends at betterhelp stepped up as a
part of this book they believe in the
book and they stepped up what i didn't
want people to do george is close this
book and say i'm ready
and they call a counselor they call a
coach and they say great we'd love to
have you six month waiting list so
betterhelp said we're gonna take that
off the table and
so if you pre-order the book now
it comes with a free month
of therapy from betterhelp and you can
have that therapy anywhere you can do it
at home on zoom you you can have therapy
where you don't have to look at somebody
you can talk to them on the phone you
can talk to them
on the computer so it's really
remarkable you can pre-order this book
for 20 bucks comes the free month
therapy and a couple other things go to
ramseysolutions.com
and pre-order own your past change your
future today george i'm pretty excited
about this thing i'm very excited too i
just got my advanced readers copy and we
got the real hard copies in just
yesterday yeah i'm pretty excited about
it it's amazing they look pretty sharp
yeah and the content's even better
is it yeah your face on the cover is not
the selling point let's just be honest
it's the words inside that can help i
know and that's never mind let's go to
cherylin in west palm beach what's up
sherilyn how are we doing
hi thank you for taking my call of
course thanks for calling what's up
so
stork fun right you pause with us still
you pause the debt snowball and then you
know just pile up cash as you're while
you're expecting
so that's what we were doing last year
and then october comes welcome to our
third baby and then november a couple
weeks later i realized hey
we've got all this money saved up and we
were down to our final debt i said we
have enough so we can
go ahead and pay off this final debt um
leaving the 1 000 emergency fund and
since babysat three is just you know
building up the fully funded emergency
fund and saving oh if we can judge when
the bill from the house will come so we
can just pay straight from that and
we'll be good to go
i was really excited to get off that
final debt so that's what we did but now
we got the bill from the hospital
and we apparently did not get our
savings built up quite enough and it
will pretty much wipe out our savings
including that starter emergency fund so
did i just really screw that up
well i i don't know if that's the right
question you probably jumped the gun a
little bit um got excited about paying
that thing off
um
so it kind of sounds like um when
someone says hey i'm getting a ten
thousand dollar bonus and so i'm gonna
go ahead and buy a ten thousand dollar
thing and the check comes in at 7 500
bucks right so
um you got excited and jumped the gun i
think the question of did i screw
something up i don't know if that's a
good use of your time right now i think
the best use of your energy and time is
so what do we do now what comes next um
because this isn't something that's
gonna happen on on repeat right unless
you get pregnant again down the road and
then you'll know let's hang on to that
that emergency fund um
have you met with the hospital about
your bills
no
okay and i do know we'll have another
one coming once there's another claim
that processes okay
um
i would strongly recommend you get the
entirety of your bill and since you have
money in saving since you've got money
in your emergency fund generally um that
you have cash that you go sit down with
the
with the hospital and say what will you
settle this for with me if i pay you in
cash right now
and here's what's critical you have to
get their offer in writing
don't give them anything
but when it comes to having a baby and
you having cash it's a win-win for
everybody they want you to have a good
experience in the hospital and so i
would sit down with them and say what
would you take for cash right now we
want to settle this bill we don't have
the full amount here how much would you
settle it for and i've heard him saying
well how much can you pay
and so you and your husband might want
to have a number in mind and say we
could do this today
and clearly it's not going to be a
wipeout for y'all you don't want to wipe
out everything you got
and the worst they can say is absolutely
not and then you can say well cool then
we'll put you on a plan and we'll pay
the best that we can as we go
most places most of the time will take
your cash in hand today and then you
will be done with this thing does that
sound good
that does sound good yes so that would
be kind of hoping for something like
that that would be my hope and again the
worst thing can say is no and if they
say no i am not going to risk my
family's future right now and completely
wipe myself out and have nothing in case
i get a flat tire on the way home so i'm
going to keep some money in my emergency
fund and i'm going to pay them what i
can what's safe for our family and then
i'm going to make regular payments with
them until we get the state knocked out
sherilyn how much are the medical bills
that you know of right now what's the
total
it's 2 800
oh it's not like
yeah it's not like a lot but
how much do you guys have in cash
well that's what we have it will if i
were to pay exactly what that bill is it
would leave us with fifty dollars in our
emergency fund
okay yeah then i mean go with what
john's saying and see what their
response is i think they'd be willing to
work with you they probably will knock
off 25 if you just paid in full and got
this thing out of there they'll take
they'll take that money now they like
that maybe you walk up with
thousand five hundred dollars in cash
and say i'll give this to you today if
we can settle this thing uh we don't
have a lot and we have 100 kids here in
fact i think we have a thousand
um we take fifteen hundred dollars in
cash and we can wipe this thing out and
they may say we'll take two thousand and
you can shake their hand and say great
and we're going to settle this and then
y'all are just going to be
running and gunning um to get that that
emergency fund built all the way to the
tip top so you can move on to baby step
four yeah thank you so much for that
call let's go out to riley in flint
michigan what's up riley
nothing from riley
riley are you there hello there we go
you spooked us hi thanks for taking my
call of course what's up
um so i'm a college student um i took
off this semester because i have some
credit card debt and just between work
and school is getting to be too much to
try and manage my debt and my finances
and work
and so i took this semester off and i've
been working on paying my credit card
off
and i actually just got um pointed in
your guys's direction about two weeks
ago
um for all the baby steps and i kind of
decided that i do want to pay off my
student loan debt and try and get try
and get all of my debt paid off i've
always been terrible with money and so
um
i'm taking some time off for school i'm
a computer science major so i i can do a
lot of stuff on my own at home i'm just
kind of wondering if it's a smart idea
to try and pay off my student loans
before going back to school
what's the total debt that you have so
how much in credit cards and how much in
student loans
for credit cards i have about twenty
three hundred and for student loans i
have about thirty five uh thousand
thirty five thousand okay and how much
school do you have left
i have uh one or sorry three semesters
left so one and a half years one and a
half years okay can you do this program
elsewhere or online that's cheaper is
this the best option
yeah i was thinking about um
transferring my credits to something a
little bit closer to home so that way i
don't have to pay for rent
but sometimes when you when you're in
your last two years you you may lose a
lot of transfer credit so i would check
on that okay don't just jump ship and
run make sure you've got good data
before you jump ship because you may run
to a school closer to home to save money
on rent but because you're in the last
two years they're going to make you
retake some courses that are specific to
their college and you may end up costing
yourself more whether in time or in
tuition riley what's your income right
now
um i think about
uh well i'm working as a male courier i
just got this job so as of right now i
think i make about 30 000 in a year okay
well here's what i'll tell you i don't
think you need to pause school and pay
off all these student loans and wait
that long but what i would do is make a
plan to cash flow the rest of your
school invest in yourself right now and
as soon as you're out and you've got a
better income we focus on crushing the
stat
yeah let's let's get this dead
let's let's get school out of the way
knock it out of the way we got to get
your income up that's part of it yeah
get this stuff out of the way and then
you can be about paying it off when you
get out of school that is another hour
in the books we'll see you shortly right
here on the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600-plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions in nashville tennessee this is
the ramsey show where america hangs out
to have a conversation about your money
and your life and your relationships and
your mental health anything that's going
on in your life
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five i'm john dalone joined
here by ramsey personality george
campbell and we're taking your calls on
just about everything give us a shout
let's go to james in atlanta georgia hey
james what's going on
how's it going uh
so i recently looked into buying a house
and i'm only 20 years old um
and
i'm wondering if based off my income and
that direct debt to income ratios is a
smart decision
um
my loan is going to be 50 of my income
oh
nope
why did you why'd you do this
how did you get into this well
well um
based on housing market and everything
and from everything everyone's told me
it's going to continue to go up right
hold on hold on
oh i want to do this i want to back out
and start the whole thing over
i'm gonna ask you what happened and then
i want you to take a hundred percent
full ownership of what you did and why
what was your thought process not what
the market did what people have been
telling you take full ownership so so
man what happened what got you in this
mess
um i got money and i had some money set
aside and i've been wanting to move out
of mom and dad's obviously um
and i wanted to invest in something to
help myself right uh
have equity and things that would bring
my equity up both noble ideas get out of
mom and dad's house and put your money
somewhere smart where you think it will
grow
so how'd you end up in this situation
with this house this particular house
that's
half of your income
um
well
talking to real estate agents and
everything um
and based off where it is i figured it
would be um
a good investment because it's an easy
sell if i needed to resell right um or
rent um and based off of that i figured
i could make enough money out of the
rent or if i reselled to make more money
um there's that option if i rented i
could make enough to pay for the
mortgage instead of
um going somewhere and running to
someone else right
uh
probably not there's a lot of
hypotheticals and then there's the
reality that 50 of your income is being
swallowed up by a mortgage and you can't
breathe
right
so where are you at in this purchase
process have you signed a purchase
agreement
uh yes i've signed of a purchase
agreement um i've already had inspectors
come out um and look at the home i'm in
the process of getting an appraisal
um
and that's where i'm at right now
appraisal and then closing into three
weeks
how much did you put down on this house
uh five percent
hopefully and it's i'm guessing a
30-year
yep
what's your earnest money what are you
in for already
so i'm in at um i think it's two grand
on earnest money okay sixteen hundred to
two grand somewhere on there
what's the total purchase price of this
house
a hundred and sixty
and
what do you do for a living
uh retail management
so what's your income
35k right now
a year
i would work with this real estate agent
and look at this contract and see what
the stipulations are to to get out of it
i mean obviously you're going to lose
your earnest money that's a best-case
scenario
and you've already put a lot of money
into this just with appraisals and
inspections and closing costs i mean
you're gonna you will lose money on this
but okay it's gonna be a short-term loss
versus
i'm telling you right now you set
yourself up to um have a hole that is
gonna take you
decades to take a while yeah
so um here's where i'm torn
you signed a contract
and do you have an ethical obligation to
see your contract through if you're a
person of character integrity
and as a person of character and
integrity you also looked in the mirror
and said what in the world am i doing
and so i would working through your
realtor i would
see about tell your realer is going to
be disappointed in you and try to talk
you out of this
you make 35 000
and you bought a 160 000 house by barely
putting any money down on it in a
white hot market
and people are are acting foolish market
you are the recipe for somebody who gets
into something that gets them in trouble
i would talk to your realtor and tell
them
you made a foolish decision
and you want to
be in talks with the
seller
and see if they will let you out of this
thing and you're gonna lose two grand
you're going to but i think it helps it
helps my heart to let the
uh seller know i made a mistake screw
this up i got in over my head i'm 20
years old i was trying to do right by me
which i love your spirit man
and by doing right by me i ended up
setting myself up for a future
catastrophe um you're gonna lose your
earnest money you probably spent four or
five or six hundred bucks to have the
house inspected um
but that's gonna be a knucklehead tax
that is gonna be well worth your time if
you can roll out of this thing
okay well
how much money did the bank approve you
for james the lender uh
160 or 155 is what it was
did you borrowed five grand from
somebody else
yeah it was my money uh my five grand
so anytime the bank says all we can give
you is this
always go way below that number
right never listen to the bank
listen to your budget and your budget
told you you're broke and the bank said
hey let's let this 20 year old use up
half of his income to pay this mortgage
because we can still make money off of
him
and let's be real clear about the state
of retail sales right now it's a mess
it's a mess
and it's unstable so yeah man i would go
call my realtor today and say i need to
sit down and talk with you in person
and look across the table over coffee
that you're going to pay for tell your
realtor i've screwed up and i need to
explore an exit strategy here and i want
to be a person of integrity i did sign a
contract i know that
i'm way way over my head and then get
out of your parents house by going to
rent an apartment man just getting apart
when i was 20 you just rent with a bunch
of dudes yeah it's a good time
you were in no place to be buying a
house that's right especially with a 35
000 year income yeah yeah so i'm not as
mad at james i am about the system that
allowed this to happen no i actually i
love james's heart man he's thinking big
and thinking he talked to some folks who
gave him some advice and he's trying to
get out there and just start swinging
man but if you get in the a ring and
start swinging to somebody that much
bigger than you man you gotta get
yourself hurt you probably follow some
youtubers and tick talkers that said
dude you got to do the house hacking
thing you can put no money down and get
into this house
and i just see a young dave ramsey who
went bankrupt that's exactly right
leveraging all this real estate and debt
and man
it just scares me for this generation
because that's what they're seeing the
parents are saying hey well you got to
get a house by now when i was your age
i paid eight thousand dollars for the
first time i remember george right after
the housing crisis um back in 0809 um i
bought a house i think in 2012. and i
went in and said i'm not going over this
amount and i was qualified for double or
triple oh yeah and i looked at my banker
and said what are you doing
i thought y'all fixed this and she goes
this is fixed and i thought oh no yikes
man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's tax season and i don't know anyone
who loves taxes
anyone who loves speak for yourself john
i'm right here
i think we talked about this but man
i got up all my tax returns i got all
the stuff sent in all like the
giving thing all the stuff in a big pile
and i sat down after the kids went to
bed like i'm gonna do my taxes and you
did it with ramsay smart tax i did it
with ramsey smart attacks i opened the
screen
and there's your face oh i apologize for
that there's your face my face is on the
home screen for some reason the team
thought that race
to get excited about taxes so those of
you who get the courage to do your taxes
just know they switch it to dave's after
oh they did yeah oh that's an excellent
move it's tax season and i don't know
anyone who loves that unless you're an
accountant
the truth is most of us dread taxes it's
a pain it's confusing and if filing
taxes wasn't bad enough the tax software
most people use hits you with extra fees
or worse
they try to sell you
debt but filing your taxes doesn't have
to be horrible we created ramsey smart
tax to give you software you can
actually trust smart tax has steps that
are simple and clear so you know you've
done your taxes right no more headaches
and second guessing yourself and will
never tack on surprise fees or sell your
info to scummy companies and will never
try to pawn you off to some debt when
you sign up for ramsey plus it's even
easier you can actually file your
federal taxes
for free and i'm saying this
not just trying to pitch this i use this
tax software in my house for my family
and it was fantastic it was quick it was
simple it was clear it was great
don't get taken advantage of by your tax
software ever again start your free
trial of ramsey plus and file your taxes
for free at ramseysolutions.com
slash ramsay plus that's ramsay
solutions.com
ramsay plus let's go to elizabeth in
philadelphia where she was born and
raised what's up elizabeth
hi can you hear me absolutely what's up
wow i can't believe i got through you
did we can't believe it either what's up
um i
so thank the lord i've been able to
avoid pretty much all forms of debt up
until
this point i have a teeny bit of credit
card debt but i'm in grad school on a
scholarship no student loans no car
payment i paid
my bachelor's degree out of pocket and
i just can kind of feel the stress of
like oh like i have like 1500 of credit
card debt i don't want that to keep
rising
um but at the same time i'm in grad
school on
a ga scholarship so i have to
you know obviously invest myself in that
for my tuition to be free
and i work part-time but i also want to
apply myself well in my school work so
yeah i just want to like think about how
to proceed wisely i just actually
downloaded the every dollar budget app
last night and it's like even with just
my bare bones expenses and like what i
can make it's like
barely making it so
i guess i don't know if it would be
worth it for me to like take out a small
loan for like expenses or
what are you studying elizabeth i'm
gonna make this work hello what are you
studying
i'm getting my master's in counseling
very cool all right so
i'm going to speak to you as a former
counseling grad student myself okay
um and you're not going to like my
response so you ready
yep
i worked full time as the dean of
students at a law school
and i was the dad of two little kids in
a
mediocre at best husband
and i worked part-time for the police
department in the middle of the night
running around doing victim services
crisis response
and a full-time phd student
so what does that mean
that
you think you're busy
but you're gonna have to turn up the gas
do love yourself enough love your future
clients enough
do not go into debt
okay
so here's what it looks like that looks
like
i just need to decompress what's a job
can i deliver ubereats and listen to
podcasts while i'm decompressing and
drop food off for people and get paid
handsomely for it
can i decompress and put headphones in
and deliver pizzas right how can i
double dip in some of these things
and i'll tell you when i graduated i
slept for days and days and days and
during your practicum when you're
actually seeing clients it's gonna be
hard to work so i would even suggest you
double up and triple up now
so that you have a little bit extra
income to get you through the practicum
season because that's hard because
you're seeing clients and you're doing
your ga work and depending on your
faculty advisor you're going to be up to
your ears and grading and all kind of
making copies and whatever else they got
you doing right
so yeah how long do you have till this
thing's done
so i'm finishing up this is my second
semester so it's a three-year program
and i just kind of like
i feel it like all right i think i can
be handling this better so i want to
kind of get on top of it now um
and
yeah my
my like motto
has always just been like oh i put stuff
on my credit cards and then i pay it off
but now it's like oh i can't keep living
this way like i don't want to be
stressed about it all the time yes and
it sounds like what you need less than
uh a loan is you need a plan
that plan is going to give you an
ability to breathe because you're going
to have a direction and not just your
fallback which is put on a credit card
which you know is making you sick it's
keeping you up at night yeah let's get a
plan and something we can work towards
so hang on the line we'll send you we're
going to put you this is our our
contribution to you who's going to be a
future mental health practitioner in
this country which we desperately need
i'm going to give you a year of ramsay
plus and it's going to come with the um
super version the souped-up version of
the everydollar app plus all the
financial peace university courses and
the budgeting tools all of it okay
that's our gift to you but you gotta
promise you're not gonna take out a loan
promise pinky promise i promise
elizabeth what are you doing right now
for your part-time work promise
um i actually do billing for a
non-profit counseling center that i love
with my whole heart
they take really good care of me so i'm
i'm working 20 hours a week for them and
then i also nanny
um
just here and there so yeah i doordashed
some too and i kind of i kind of cut
back on that a little bit because i was
feeling myself getting kind of exhausted
but at the same time like i'd rather be
exhausted now and not be in debt so oh i
love that yes hey
plan on it okay
the next two years is gonna be tough
make no mistake i've walked those shoes
it's gonna be tough it's gonna be hard
and you're gonna be exhausted
and i will tell you being on the other
side of it graduating without any
student loan debt my first degree um my
first phd my wife and i we graduated
household total of six figures
i graduated my second phd debt free and
i'm gonna tell you there's a drastic
difference because you know what i could
do after graduation anything i wanted to
because i didn't owe anybody anything
you know what i mean yeah and i i thank
goodness i was able to pay my bachelor's
degree out of pocket from working two
jobs absolutely like so i kind of know i
kind of know like the struggle and then
like the release so there you go okay
sounds like that's the thing to do so
hang on the line here kelly's gonna hook
you up i want you to make a plan get a
budget get one of your grad school
compadres to walk alongside you um they
can watch the videos with you y'all can
make budgets together and i know that
sounds oh this sounds super lame gloony
i'm telling you your clients on the
other end are going to be grateful that
you're not coming into sessions
completely stressed out because you
don't know how to pay the student loan
off or when they throw
um all the
sessions online and you don't know how
to do zoom counseling because they've
closed down you know services again that
you're not gonna be losing sleep because
you have all these bills to pay okay
let's get through this thing debt free
debt free not fun george no let's just
get this this is a big thing though john
a lot of people you know they give us
grief over our advice about just
graduating debt-free and we never said
it was easy we never go it's a piece of
cake anyone can do it we go it's gonna
be a lot of work you're gonna be working
while you're in school which by the way
tends to increase your gpa if you're
doing it a reasonable amount you know 15
20 hours a week like she is but it's so
worth it because the people that call in
who said i graduated debt-free they have
options they get to choose the job they
want they get to live where they want
versus the people who call in and they
go i got 100 000 in student loan debt i
can't breathe i have to do the job that
i hate i have to live here here's the
stipulations because i'm chained to this
debt i i am uber compassionate about
most things
but
not this i i i've walked that walk right
this one's hard and so you got to suck
it up and you got to do what you got to
do and it might be your school's too
expensive it might be means i got to let
this one thing go i love this agency but
they don't pay me enough so i gotta go
do doordash which doesn't sound as cool
as this but this one pays the bills you
got to make some hard choices sometimes
and you gotta work and you gotta work
and you gotta work but again the light
on the other tunnel is so good it's so
worth it she's doing the budget she just
got off so good it's gonna be a game
changer so good hey we'll be right back
on the ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help
go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use promo code ramsey to get the best
deal today's question comes from amanda
in illinois my fiance and i are getting
married in april we both own our own
homes and plan on selling his home and
living in mine where we disagree is the
timing of when he will contribute
financially to the mortgage and house
bills i think he should start
contributing when he moves in
he doesn't want to contribute until he
sells his home because with his child
support and his mortgage he can't afford
to pay half of my bills i'd be fine with
this if he were proposing to make up the
difference after the sale of the home
but he is not he feels that i'm being
mercenary to suggest that he pay me for
these expenses my other concern is that
the wedding is two months out and he has
not yet met with a realtor or made steps
to put his house on the market
so amanda
let's just pretend me and you
were
i don't know hanging out
and you told me this story i would tell
you unequivocally my sister my sister
called with this
i would say absolutely do not get
married
stop
um i would tell my fiance in this
situation um i'm gonna pause the wedding
and we need to go talk to somebody and
see if this is really what we want to do
you are headed for a train wreck
and it's coming right at you
oh boy
yeah george there's so many problems
with this he could be heading to a
second divorce here money fights and
money problems number one cause of
divorce in america and they are about to
run into a wall with their finances well
just the way they're talking this is my
half this is your half you sell this and
also this is a bad business deal you owe
that's exactly what the transaction is a
bad transaction
and this is not a two people coming
together to say uh two of us are
becoming one of us and we're gonna do
life together
and this is you owe me and you gotta pay
me back and i don't this is a recipe for
disaster amanda
and i'm sorry that somebody in your life
who loves you hasn't said what are you
doing
i'm sorry that somehow and i've just
heard about this over and over that you
know the train gets going like hey will
you marry me yes and then all sudden it
just sneaks up on us and we haven't had
these hard conversations but
um this is gonna be a disaster you're
gonna end up married with two homes he's
gonna hang on to what that home means to
him and his
singleness or whatever and then it's
gonna be
you're gonna be in a mess
uh i recommend y'all stop the presses on
everything doesn't mean you have to go
through with stopping the presses but i
would throw a flag here pause everything
and then go see a marriage counselor
asap
um
what should happen is his house should
have already been sold
or should be under contract or should at
least have a sign out in the yard
that y'all are trying to actively get
rid of this thing together
and
then he will move into y'all's home
and y'all will pay y'all's bills
together
and child support will become y'all's
child support because y'all are going to
spend money together on things that
y'all have to spend money on
and there's not my bills and his bills
and he's got to pay his child support it
is our child support it's our bills
um
yeah for combining our income when we're
married then it's not as much of a
question of well he's paying his
mortgage and i'm paying my mortgage and
he should be contributing it becomes hey
we're in this middle of this weird we
have two house payments that we have to
take care of and both of our incomes are
going to cover that right and how it
shakes down and how we fight over that's
that's not going to be part of the
equation absolutely not um and yes two
months out and he has not yet met with a
realtor that or made steps to put his
house on the market that tells me
something else is there that's a flag on
the play that's right um i don't know
much about sports but i think that's
what they say that was excellent thank
you that was the
full view it didn't well i just thought
i see that you wrote that down and
you've been waiting to use that lag on
the sports reference that would be great
to insert sometime because i don't know
much about them it's gonna make me sound
tough and masculine all right let's go
to glen in los angeles california what's
up glenn
hey guys how are you doing what up
yeah i'm doing great what's up
uh so i'm active duty marine
my i got served to horse papers uh
december i've got a three-year-old child
and i'm receiving orders to go to a new
school for a new job in september i'm
sorry uh two questions one i'm not sure
how to budget
uh
because my wife used to do all that
and um two i'm not sure how to budget
with um because i get basically for
housing i'm not sure where that fits in
if i
want to
buy or rent a house and how much
percentage that would equate to if that
makes sense yeah absolutely man so what
happened why she served your papers
uh she's just um
just said she's not
not happy anymore we've been we've been
through counseling a couple times we've
been married five years
maybe six years this may
um
she's just not happy
she's finally got her own career going
off the ground now
she's in the air force as well yeah um
and uh she just wants to go in a
different direction we're still we're
amicable it's not like we're not having
big fights or anything he's just we work
better as friends we decided and uh
just to try to make it as best we can
for our daughter yeah and i'm sorry
that's uh even when it's amicable it's a
it's a mess so
um especially you throw a sweet little
baby three sweet little baby girl in
there man things get complex and that's
that's a lot of heartache man um
so
i'll talk about the the service uh i
mean the housing allowance and then we
can roll over georgia and walk you
through the budgeting um
when it comes to the service
you get with your service housing
allowance right um
do you have to use that on base or can
you take that off
uh you can that's basically i i can use
it anywhere okay uh it's based on the
zip code the base is at that i'd be
stationed at that so it fluctuates
depending on where you go but it yeah it
can be used for private
housing buying a house renting an
apartment will you get paid during
school too
uh yeah i'll still be getting my basic
pay and stuff because it's military
school for another occupation okay so
really at the housing allowance becomes
income right you're just going to budget
that as though you would add it on right
and there's not a cap is there like you
can't use it for three years they're
gonna cut you off
uh no as long as i have uh yeah no i'll
be good
i'm gonna strongly strongly strongly
strongly recommend having lived in
multiple military cities with bases
please don't run out and buy
a big house
or in any house in a community that
you're going to live 24 months in okay
um i know that's the cool thing and
they're like well i can just run it and
i can do this that's i've just seen
service member after service member get
themselves in trouble doing that and
then they make these special
va loans for you it just lets you walk
in the front door i'd much rather see
you rent long term that's going to be
better for you if you think you're going
to stay somewhere five six seven ten
years which
i know that's that's fanciful thinking
um if you're active duty yeah um then
you settle down and buy a house man but
most folks get themselves into some
pretty serious trouble they can't get
out of the house it just becomes a
quagmire okay um but yeah take that as
income and dump it on top of your
regular basic pay and that's you're
going to look at that broadly speaking
then george will walk you through the
budgets yeah glenn uh you know we have
about a minute till we had to break here
but here's what i'm going to do i'm
going to gift you one year of ramsay
plus that's our online membership that
will give you access to financial peace
university all the video courses our
every dollar plus premium budgeting tool
that connects to your bank account i
want you to do this create your first
budget and to make it easy on you rachel
cruz our friend has a course in there
called budgeting that actually works so
watch that one first to get a handle on
budgeting then go through all the
financial peace university videos but
it's simple you're going to pay
attention to where your money's going
every single dollar is going to have a
job no dollars go unemployed all of your
income minus your expenses equals zero
and we're going to cut the frivolous
stuff are you have any debt right now
yes uh after this is all settled i'll
probably have about um thirty thousand
in debt and uh funny you said about the
va loan house we do have a house in
north carolina that will become mine
it's currently being rented out um
all right yeah i do want to think about
selling i would take advantage of the
market and i would sell that house be be
clean on this deal
and um yeah take that extra money and
hey hang on the line not only we're
going to give your mz plus but i'm
grateful for your service my brother and
i'm going to give you a copy of total
money makeover this is dave's book
that's going to walk you through it i'm
going to give you a copy of my new book
own your past change your future you got
some stuff that you got to walk through
some healing and then you got to be
about what comes next and my book is
going to walk you through that so we're
going to give you all this stuff we're
grateful for your heart and for your
service let's start today getting well
we'll talk to you soon
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture of the day is
philippians 1 9 and this is my prayer
that your love may overflow more and
more with knowledge and full insight
oliver wendell holmes says a moment's
insight is sometimes worth a life's
experience
let's go out to rex in philadelphia
pennsylvania what's going on rex
how you doing how you doing john and
george excellent how are you
fantastic so what's up man how can we
help
i'm 25 an accountant and i have 37 000
left in my baby still student loans i'm
trying to do side hustles to speed up my
baby uh step two uh so i do accounting
and virtual assistance work for both of
my parents's businesses
uh but i haven't been paid yet
did y'all have an agreement yeah
uh no so this is the issue it's um how
do i bring up
paying me again and how much of a
discount from the market should my work
be
oh
man i
george hop in here i so
your parents needed some tax work you're
an accountant and they said hey will you
help out and you said sure i'll help out
and you did taxes for your parents
and you
all
it's all bookkeeping you know not i do
need tax work i was a tax accountant for
a couple of years so i know how to do
taxes but it's all bookkeeping work it's
part consulting as well um so i mean
from accounting to operations to social
media anything you can think of that's
what i'm involved in and this was all
just the kind of a handshake yeah i'll
help you out no one agreed on pricing
no no
yeah so it's the deal man you're not
getting paid on this
no um would i
my path forward here if i'm you would be
one of two things
mom and dad i did this free last year
i'm trying to pay off the remaining debt
um and so i'm gonna have to go get jobs
that are paid jobs i love helping you
guys out it makes my heart feel good i
love people take care of it um if you
all are interested in hiring me to take
do this work this year i would love to
stay but i've got to go get some paying
jobs
i think you're going to be
um
it could be viewed as you lacking
integrity to circle back and demand
payment for something that somebody
thought you were just helping out with
because you all didn't have the
conversation on the front end
and we had a conversation about me being
paid i just haven't been paid yet like
this it's kind of great because they
don't even know what to pay you you said
you didn't ask for a specific number
yeah
so tell me about this pay conversation
yes i mean it was more a conversation of
saying hey
all right i know that i've done this
stuff for you guys in the past but you
know that i'm trying to pay off my
student debt i'm doing these baby steps
my mother actually uh did the dave
ramsey
way getting out of her dead after their
divorce
so she knows what i'm doing
um but my dad i do more work for him i
just told him i said hey like i need to
be paid and he just basically told me i
don't he didn't have like an answer for
me when i said hey
how much you know what's your number you
know and i said i i would like to be
paid can you let me know but i'm kind of
getting ghosted and he needs things for
me
but i don't really know
when i'm going to get that that number
back to say hey like i'm trying to work
with their budget
also but i still need to figure out how
much i should be charging them so i'm
like in this weird space yeah i don't
know what my number is and they won't
tell me theirs all right so let's let's
back out here let's take them off the
table okay okay you can control two
things on planet earth your thoughts and
your actions that's it
that's it yeah so
just because you know what they have
doesn't mean that is the appropriate
amount for you to be paid either up or
down
right
um yeah
so you've got a couple of boundary
issues that you need to work through
number one you just come up with a
market value for racks right
number two you got to come up with pro
bono racks
i do pro
coaching behind closed doors all over
the country people call in and i work
with them and
um
people who are struggling with various
diseases and that's in a friend of a
friend that kind of thing um yeah but
i'm able to do that because dave takes
care of us well right and i've got other
other income streams
what you're gonna have to decide and is
there a mom and dad rate that's there's
not really a good way to do that other
than you just say this is mom and dad
rate and if they can't meet it they
can't meet it um you and your dad are
gonna get into a staring contest and
what's gonna suffer is thanksgiving
what's going to suffer is christmas
what's going to suffer is your
relationship with your dad
and i'm going to put the onus on you
that you did work without a contract
with a without a firm number because if
you had said i'm going to charge 20 000
bucks and he said deal and he's not
paying
then he's the guy that's got to look in
the mirror right but y'all didn't do
that you said hey uh i did some stuff
and i kind of like to be paid he's like
well how much like i don't know how much
you got and it's like i don't know how
much you got man i i would chalk this
one up too i learned a hard lesson and
now i gotta go be about getting paid
and i wouldn't i wouldn't beat my
parents up over it um because i didn't
do the hard work on the front end of
setting those boundaries and setting
those prices yeah this has become like a
three two one draw what's your number
what's your number we'll meet in the
middle it just doesn't work like that
especially those family right yeah so
dust your hands
and we move forward and go hey going
forward here's what i need to charge
otherwise it's been fun working with you
all i can steer in the right direction
get you someone else who can help but i
can't do this any longer because i care
about this relationship more than i do
the business transaction
and rex yeah i want to give you one more
piece of delaney wisdom cool
it's not not gonna cost you anything so
it might be worth what i'm what i'm
charging you for it okay
any moment after you hang up the phone
with me and george any moment
that you spend angry about this
is a choice for you to be miserable
you're choosing misery
any
any second you spend on resenting your
parents after this moment after you hang
up the phone
is a choice to intentionally poison
yourself hoping somebody else gets sick
okay so at some point i want you to find
peace in your heart about this deal
you did a lot of work you were had your
fingers behind your back crossed hoping
you get paid and you didn't
you learned a lesson man and it's
probably disappointing that your parents
didn't circle up and be like hey we are
so grateful for your work we're so
grateful for your dave ramsey journey
we're gonna give you fifty thousand
dollars to help you out that'd be great
and you may even be able to see in the
books and know they can afford it what
makes this whole thing worse
but yeah they didn't they didn't
and if they want to hire you great i'll
even cut your mom and dad deal but we're
gonna do it with a contract we're not
gonna do the handshake i'm your old man
you're gonna give me a contract
absolutely yes sir um i'm running a
professional business i gotta keep up
with my taxes my work and there's gonna
be a
push back there but there's also going
to be some respect there's some mutual
respect business to business i'm cutting
you a 50 dad deal a 75 off that deal
whatever it is um but we're gonna do
this above board everybody's gonna be on
the same page so that we all know
we can all we can all share thanksgiving
dinner with smiles on our faces is that
fair yeah
yeah definitely i know that hurts man i
know that hurts hey and by the way you
do good work right
yeah of course you work hard
very then charge what you're worth
cool yeah george what's your worst
it's tough when you when it's your
parents you know i feel like in some way
kind of get into
you know not lending your family money
but in anything with the dollar sign
attached to it it's like this person is
partially responsible for me being alive
it's really tough to ask them for you
know for money you know especially rex
the truth is i wouldn't work for my
parents i was just the truth i wouldn't
either oh if i it's the same as is
loaning money um i'm not going to loan
money to my family members i might give
them some and so i'm not going to charge
my mom and dad unless i'm a hired
employee
the same way you know rachel cruz works
for dave ramsey and they have an
agreement as part of her contract that's
written out so that everybody knows
who's paying what and who's getting paid
what
that's different if i'm doing something
for my parents i'm just going to help
them out and do it
i'm not going to i'm not going to charge
my parents like that we say to be
unclear is to be unkind and so we've got
to be clear we've got to communicate
we've got to have the boundaries in
place so that it doesn't cause
resentment and hurt these relationships
yeah think long term but hey you learned
a lesson how old are your ex
i am 25. brother it took me to my
mid-30s before i realized how much
clarity helps my family relationships
both my marriage my parents my brothers
and sisters everybody so you learned
this a decade ahead of me you're way way
ahead of the game my brother clarity is
everything clarity is everything and if
you don't feel like i can charge my
parents either do the work for free or
say i don't have time to do it this time
that's hard george yeah that's tough i
mean just boundaries in general we've
taken a lot of calls this week where
it's just people didn't put clear enough
boundaries up and then there's
resentment and then it hurts the
relationship and it always points back
to you when you have to go that's that's
on me i didn't set up the boundaries and
so next time i'm going to be good about
boundaries that wraps up today's show i
want to thank james and ben and kelly
even zach
thank you all for a great show george
you're getting there man thank you you
did a good job no hard you're trying
real hard i'm john deloney in america
we're so grateful that you join us be
kind to one another be kind turn the
devices off and go play we'll see you
soon
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you